de nos jours de repos de cette
compilation de jeux on commence avec
sakura cliqueurs qui est un jeu où il
faut juste cliquer maintenant seule
petite particularité les mecs se sont
dit bon quitte à cliquer autant cliquez
sur 2,9 avec des gros seins
du coup on en est là il faut appuyer sur
ces vilaines ennemis pour les battre et
gagner des niveaux et des pièces aux
mondiaux un coffre est sorti et d'entre
ces singes le louvre et il y à des
pièces de danger ou chez les internautes
parce que plus connu ces héros qu un
truc du genre tu cliques sur des
monstres des méchants là c'est carrément
des meufs à poil donc là on passe dès
l'aube elle est on va boire à tort au
honduras coffre est sorti de son cul
ouah les pièces du coup on fait quoi ils
ces [ __ ] piège vous achète des cinq
mois par notre force
ok on vous dit je peux acheter des épées
et coûte 1 euro attend attend à thonon
pour juste cliquer sur des dessins ça va
l'asie moi je m'embête c'est que
j'améliore la force à fond au [ __ ]
fait super mal à s'y perdre d'argent
s'il ne sait pas trop si c'est femme
apprécie ou pas ce qui se passe au
regard des accueils rock anthem patty
faith est là tu rougis je vais devant
2016 c'est formidable au dessus des
vagues d'ennemis qui surfait des baffes
à poil alors peut pas jeter autre chose
19 mille pièces auto attaque massive
très camillo les mecs faut cliquer
combien de fois alors je découvre les
cliques heures l'as abusé alors qu'il
tournait sein sur les seins dans la boue
la whey pour gaza puis 60 gold accord au
caire n'évolue qu'à pas sur son visage
est une donne 60 e gold c'est génial
c'est meilleur jeu du monde avec
europcar manque une carrière que sur les
mii a pas de problème quoi je peux taper
le nuage ça marche peut taper la
ceinture ça marche
génial best game ever j'achète de la
force obscure en bas de life tient la
même date on est déjà 2100 là on va pas
avoir ça bientôt attend la bosse elle a
beaucoup dit là y'a plus de piques à
l'absence a pas du tout bon dieu c'est
des belles filles maintenant c'est
incroyable si tu as la même architecture
à ya juste le petit succès au dessus qui
change
au québec on peut acheter une auto
attaque attention qu'est ce que ça fait
effet 75% des dégâts d'un clic toutes
les 1,5 seconde ses bases à saissac et
sa clique tout seul tout est à 25
secondes a du coup tu peux carrément
partir une plus jouer quoi y'a vraiment
plus aucun plaisir
tu as joué comme d'habitude 10500
évaluation très positif quoi je découvre
d'ailleurs déclic heure là nous
retourner leur compte et de recommander
500 euros tous la dernière mise à jour a
su priver va sauvegarde
c'est à retirer mon argent mais alliance
ma progression tout vers si les
développeurs 500 heures à cliquer sur
des dessins et sa sauvegarde allait
supprimer plus tard maintenant sur pen
ont eu lieu et la zone emea cliquez sur
les dessins il voulait passer à autre
chose
bonjour a déjà acquis au moins on va
danser et à demain celui demandé je sais
pas ce qu'elle dit mais elle doit dire
dégage [ __ ] bonjour et très mais là tu
attends je la tenais mais c'est parce
que je m'arrête à la tiens tiens tiens
les tétées mais c'est abusif des
allergies à son bord plusieurs frappes
hier aient tout à fait tapis mais tu
veux quoi toi tu arrêtes tu es pas
content de fallu fermer la porte aux
quais avec m e toi petit coup dans tes
yeux ronds nyala est foncée jfpi telle
gifle et plusieurs mecs avant moi on est
plein de nuances baiia s'est fait
défoncer je peux pas sortir du banc
sinon et m'excuser
le japon va nous interdire de faire des
jeux indés un second possible elle m'a
tuer on est mort attendez si on a pas il
se passe quoi je le savoir n'a
d'ailleurs hockey ont fait la paix ont
fait la paix ont fait d'après tu me
laisses d'un combat je te laisse dans
mon bas certains marchés commerciaux n'a
pas marché même tape à royat qui met le
premier coup c'est toi moi ce que tu
mets ta couche permet une petite salle
de claire comme ça dans le nez bof tu as
abusé ou en tout cas n'avait jamais
frappé quelqu'un dans son bain n'est
d'ailleurs jamais dans le bras de
quelqu'un tout court d'ailleurs c'est
fini on a vu c'est tout voilà c'est un
vrai plaisir
mais ces dames cette vidéo été crescendo
puisque dès maintenant sur real time
lover c'est parti bonjour tâche tout à
fait dans fait exprès pourquoi le brent
bat de baseball est ce que je pourrais
jouer dans ce jeu vidéo ok c'était
l'intro du jeu c'était l'intro du jeu
pourquoi boissons qu il suit chez moi
c'est génial
un verbe arrêter de montrer les culottes
s'il vous plaît dans la barre arrêtez
s'il vous plaît allez sous peu joué non
mais regardez tous les piles et diallo
mecque des filles est ce qu'à un moment
on peut jouer haut il suffisait de
demander à temps c'est abusé quand tu
achètes ce jeu tu dois taper huit heures
de cinématiques avant de jouer quoi je
suis pas de procès mais dégage toi a été
repoussée pas oula oula oula oula wet
vous les filles tâche week end à la
démission et à saveur mais bien
forcément un délire à cette maison ça
mais non avec des [ __ ] de caisse
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont autant de
filles autour de nous brosse à lui
comment ça va je voulais pas sortir ceux
ci excuse-moi well as peur n'ayez pas
peur via vient mais mais bien je veux
juste qu'on sakura siamois quoi ça ça
cool a annoncé le pain est juste un
éléphant plastiques danse moi je me
sépare du québec m'écouter ya des vieux
bruit on dirait qu'il ait un qui joue y
regarder c'est juste des toilettes avec
dans l'évier des clubs et des sous
vêtements partout dans cette maison est
certain qu'il fait ce bruit tout seul
vrai pouvoir est ce que c'est toi bien
grandi je suis confus tout le nom mais
il va par clic and run et max donc aucun
[ __ ] de sens il ya encore une clope
parterre de vaugrenier mais il se passe
des choses
je me bats j'en peux plus de cette vidéo
question qu'est ce que tu fais dans ses
murs des paniers on avait dit pas les
murs ça suffise non pas le sous sol non
plus bonjour j'ai pas de cette vidéo sur
ces trois jeux japonais extrêmement
bizarre dès cette année mais ça vous a
plu
on aura appris quand même qu'il ne faut
pas rejoindre une inconnue dans son bain
on ne savait pas avant à l'adresse de
prochaine vidéo merci d'avoir gardé
porter ou via un chat bis